fue en el último vídeo en donde
estábamos trabajando con la calculadora
para estimar dos soluciones de este
sistema de este sistema de ecuaciones no
lineales lo que buscábamos era en qué
punto se interceptaban estas dos curvas
el lugar y natural de 3x y esta función
que tengo aquí y bueno nuestra
estimación la hicimos en decimos es
decir dentro de 0.1 nos fijamos en los
décimos y aquí hicimos nuestra
estimación sin embargo nosotros sacamos
algunas conclusiones en el vídeo pasado
una de ellas era que por ejemplo este no
era el punto de intersección de ambas
curvas de una manera exacta de hecho el
punto de intersección entre ambas curvas
estaba entre 1 y 0.9 entre 0.9 y 1 es
decir cerca de aquí y por otra parte el
otro punto en donde se interceptaban
estas dos curvas estaban entre 2.8 y 2.7
bueno nosotros concluimos que las
soluciones más cercanas a decimos eran
estas dos pero qué te parece si en esta
ocasión tratamos de acercarnos un poco
más
lo que quiero que veas es que tengo el
presentimiento y parece ser que nuestras
soluciones ni siquiera son números
racionales deben de ser números
irracionales por cómo se comporta y cómo
es la función logaritmo y más la función
logaritmo natural por lo tanto yo estoy
casi seguro que por más que nos
intentemos acercar siempre vamos a estar
cada vez más y más y más cerca del punto
de intersección pero encontrarlo no creo
que sea nada fácil así que bueno para
esto voy a trabajar con un programa que
tiene mi computadora el cual nos va a
ayudar bastante en entender qué es lo
que está pasando con estas dos funciones
es un gráfica d'or en este programa
podemos poner las dos funciones y vamos
a pedirle que nos gráfica las dos
funciones y además vamos a intentar
aproximarnos lo más que se pueda a los
puntos de intersección así que bueno
recordemos la primera ecuación era el
logaritmo natural ok de a voy a abrir
paréntesis de 3x ok y si yo le pido a
este programa que me la gráfica entonces
le voy a dar
este botón de aquí y ya está si te das
cuenta está de color negro por lo tanto
voy a cambiarle de color
y para esto está aquí esta herramienta
le voy a cambiar de color para que
podamos visualizarla mejor
le voy a cambiar al color naranja este
color me gusta por lo tanto voy a
cambiar este color y voy a cambiar este
color y ya la tengo aquí la función
logaritmo natural de 3x ahora vamos a
pedirle a este programa que también
podamos poner justo ahorita otra
ecuación así que vamos a agregar una
nueva ecuación una nueva función y por
lo tanto vamos a escribir la otra
función que según me acuerdo era y
primero hay que poner un símbolo de
fracción que creo que es este de aquí
ok y me quedaba x elevada donde está
este botón creo que es este no creo que
es este perfecto x elevado al cuadrado a
esto le quitábamos x y después le
sumábamos 1 ok y todo eso si te acuerdas
lo dividimos entre x ahora ya tengo la
siguiente función y vamos a
este botón para que me la gráfica de
lujo aquí esta gráfica da esta función y
déjame cambiar de color le voy a cambiar
a un color al color azul para que la
veamos de color azul de lujo entonces
déjame cerrar esto de aquí y estoy aquí
y si te das cuenta esta parte esta parte
se parece muchísimo a lo que nosotros
veíamos en nuestra gráfica que tenemos
aquí abajo fíjate bien fíjate en esta
parte y ahora nos fijamos en esta
gráfica y son muy parecidas aquí tengo a
rx y lx y por lo tanto aquí en este
programa también voy a tener a l de x y
de x aquí está de lujo ahora qué te
parece si para empezar a nos acercamos
un poco más a estos puntos de
intersección y para eso lo que voy a
hacer es modificar la escala y voy a
agarrar un rango tanto en x como un
james más cercano estos dos puntos de
intersección así que vamos a hacerlo
para esto voy a poner los límites que
quieran ok y ya los tengo aquí quiero
que x vaya desde este punto desde 0.8
desde 0.8 ok hasta este punto vamos a
alejarnos no tanto vamos a acercarnos al
3 me voy a poner en el valor de 3 ok de
0.8 hasta 3 ok y voy a poner una escala
de 0 punto que te parece de 0.5 para que
se vea con mayor exactitud ahora en
yemen me interesa ver qué es lo que pasa
desde bueno puedo empezar desde aquí
desde 0.8 vamos a ponerlo desde 0.8
hasta bueno llegábamos hasta el 2 y
tantos entonces le voy a poner hasta el
3 hasta el 3 de lujo entonces se va a
acercar más todo esto y ya aquí tenemos
las dos funciones en un rango que me
hace visualizar mucho mejor los puntos
de intersección es este punto de aquí y
este punto de aquí atrás los que vamos
lo que se me ocurre hacer para encontrar
estos puntos de intersección es pedirle
al mismo programa que me busque los
puntos de intersección y vamos a ver con
qué esa actitud me los encuentra así que
para esto vamos a seleccionar estas dos
funciones esta y esta las dos ok y ahora
voy a poner que me busque que me busque
la intersección entre ellos ok me dice
te voy a buscar la intersección de entre
ellos y le voy a pedir que me lo busque
fíjate precisamente por aquí en el 0.9
cerca del 0.9 que fue nuestra conclusión
en el vídeo pasado fíjate bien aquí en
el vídeo pasado llegamos a que el punto
estaba cercano a 0.9 por lo tanto vamos
a ponerle 0.9 y 2.7 que busquen una
intersección entre estas dos curvas
cerca muy cerca de estos puntos y vamos
a ver con cuántos decimales me estima
esta solución así que busquemos otra vez
el programa y estaba por aquí ya no
tengo ok no está por aquí ok de lujo
ahora le estoy pidiendo a este programa
que cerca del 0.9 me encuentre la
intersección y bueno
él me dice que la intersección se
encuentra muy cerca de 0.91 35 y que
bien vale 1.00 82 de lujo que estamos
justo aquí en este punto que parece ser
una buena estimación al punto de
intersección ahora si te das cuenta su
estimación es mucho mejor que la nuestra
es 0.9 135 y nosotros solamente nos
quedamos en 0.9 pero lo que ya podemos
ver es que este punto de intersección
está mucho más cerca de 0.9 que lo que
estaba de 1 además fíjate que aquí nos
está estimando hasta decimos centésimos
milésimas diezmilésimos hasta 10
milésimas que no se me hace nada malo y
también nos da el valor de hasta 10
milésimas ahora estamos cerca de este
punto de aquí pero yo estoy segurísimo
que no acaba aquí todo esto de hecho tú
podrías meter en tu calculadora el valor
de 0.9 135 evaluarlo en las dos
funciones tanto el logaritmo natural de
3x como en la función x
- x1 todo eso entre x y para saber que
no te va a dar el mismo valor te va a
dar un valor muy pero muy pero muy
cercano pero encontrar el punto el punto
de intersección no es nada sencillo
tanto que ni siquiera este programa lo
puede hacer ahora otra cosa que quiero
aclararte es que este programa te dará
una estimación hasta diezmilésimos cosa
que está bastante bien sin embargo tú
puedes encontrar otros programas otros
gráfica dores u otras calculadoras
gráfica doras que te den este valor con
mucho más exactitud y puede ser una
mejor estimación si tú tienes una
calculadora o un programa que haga esto
inténtalo por ti mismo a ver hasta qué
valor te puede dar ahora busquemos el
otro punto de intersección que estaba
cerca de 2.7 te acuerdas entonces voy a
sustituir a x por 2.7 y le voy a pedir
en esta ocasión a este programa a este
gráfica dor que me busque un punto de
intersección cercano cercano a 2.7 a ver
que me encuentra así que le voy a dar
aquí y ya me mando para acá ahora
estamos justo justo en este punto de
aquí
este punto de aquí lo más que se acerca
este programa es hasta disminuimos otra
vez y me dice que el valor en el cual se
intersectan ambas curvas es 2.7 432
donde james es decir l de x y rx su
valor se aproxima a 2.10 77 y es este
valor de aquí así que no estábamos tan
mal nosotros pusimos 2.7 y si te das
cuenta si estamos más cercanos a 2.7 de
lo que estamos a 2.8 pero este programa
al menos me lo calcula hasta
diezmilésimos y parece tener una mejor
mucho mejor estimación que lo que
nosotros habíamos calculado ahora vuelvo
a aclarar yo creo que es una buena
estimación pero tal vez existan
programas o calculadoras gráfica dora's
que lo hagan mucho mejor y se acerquen
mucho pero mucho pero mucho más al punto
de intersección y bueno también por lo
tanto te va a dar un mejor valor para
jane y bueno la otra es que no creo que
haya ningún programa que te dé el punto
exacto porque estoy segurísimo bueno muy
seguro de que es un valor irracional y
los irracionales ya sabes que son muy
y vuelvo a pedirte que te parece si te
acercas a 2.74 32 lo sustituyese en tu
calculadora en estas dos expresiones
tanto en la función l de x como en ere
de x y para saber que no vas a llegar
exactamente al valor de 2.10 77 va a ser
ir a un valor muy cercano en ambas pero
bueno este programa al menos menos
gráfica no los pone muy cercanos justo
aquí ahora voy a intentar
voy a intentar acercar un poco más a
este punto de intersección a este punto
de intersección y para eso voy a acercar
la imagen ok le voy a pedir que se
acerque a este punto de kiel entonces
vamos a acercarnos ok ya perdí la
gráfica estamos un poco más abajo y
bajamos un poco ok
bajemos un poco y estábamos cerca de
2.74 y algo de cuerdas entonces me voy a
acercar más para acá más para acá voy a
bajar un poco fíjate como las dos
gráficas se van acercando se van
acercando se van acercando se van
acercando se van acercando y de hecho si
nosotros no
adelantamos un poco más un poco más un
poco más un poco más un poco más un poco
más un poco más un poco más un poco más
vamos a ver qué se van a interceptar
estas dos curvas así que creo que vamos
bastante bien
vamos a moverle un poco más ya para que
no se encuentre el punto de intersección
y justo aquí donde tenemos el punto de
intersección date cuenta que nos da un
valor muy cercano al que nos estaba
dando hace rato dos puntos 74 30 y 22
puntos 74 32 de hecho tenemos la misma
escala aquí lo que quiere decir que el
programa no se puede acercar más a este
punto pero vuelvo a insistir se me hace
un muy pero muy pero muy pero muy buen
valor de aproximación si me trató de
acercar más a fíjate que la escala sigue
igual
ok bueno creo que eso es todo por este
vídeo y te invito a que tú agarres tu
propio programa gráfica door o tu
calculadora gráfica dora e intentes con
estas dos ecuaciones buscar el punto de
intersección a ver si te da un valor un
poco más preciso mejor estimado y además
de que tú intentes encontrar la mejor
aproximación que puedas sobre el punto
de intersección de éstas
curvas o en donde estas dos curvas son
iguales
hasta la próxima